Maybe in the history of fine art
Diego Velasquez's Menin (or "Flippin's Family")
the table that needs to be analyzed
little ones
Even though the painter lives at the end of his life, while the masterpiece we talk about
He was at the highest point of his creations. Therefore,
all his talents, experience, thoughts
skillfully skirt over the canvas.
At that time, Velasquez was a court painter working for the Spanish king IV Philip,
He has been in this post for more than thirty years.
He was, of course, the Philippines's favorite artist,
has repeatedly drawn his portrait,
both the salary and the rank of the president have gradually risen.
The artist, who is the palace manager,
The great Alkasar palace in Madriddin
decorated with his own works of art.
Not surprisingly, for the masterpiece
Velasquez himself is best known in the palace
space - personally chosen
the workshop decorated with works.
At present, it is difficult to see what is described in these paintings, but it is well-known that the space conformity
and the selection of these works is not accidental.
But after a while ...
First, let's look at the general picture:
Very detailed details;
Perhaps, first of all, the little girl draws attention,
Margaret Therese.
The only surviving king of the king.
Or maybe you see the mirror of the king and the queen.
Or, first, six of the top 9 images are in focus,
They look at you in the background as if you were in the background.
This element alone gives the impression of painting,
you know, you've froze that moment ...
Velasquez described a moment as some of the figures
he saw something and his attention was disturbed.
These three are still unaware ...
The little princess looks just at her eyes.
It involves spontaneity in the scene,
The entire composition of the image is interesting.
Every figure described in the group is unique.
What does Velasquez have in this 11-person team?
Including the mirror of the queen and the queen
unusual similarities and contradictions have been created.
This makes the eyes look more detailed on the canvas.
The first interesting point is the dual and triple groups.
Each figure, apart from the shahzad, is a couple.
Male and female dwarfs,
two backhanders standing behind,
The royal mausoleum, standing in the roof of the girl and the rear corridor,
the king and the queen on the mirror
and a girl who bows down with Velasquez and gives a drink to the queen.
Each of these dual figures consists of women and men.
The distinctive accent is the only lady in the center of the stage.
However, the images can also be grouped into three groups:
Prince and two assistants, dogs and two dwarfs, with two men in charge of the palace
the man in the corridor, the artist and the pair of mirrors.
There are two types of triangular shapes in both groups
and all of them are described on the same horizontal surface.
This 6-person group also creates a three-dimensional illustration by expanding the scope of the painting.
The views are moving from the Velaskes in the front to the court officer in the background,
because both are in the same black lipstick and are on the same line with the rear doors.
The palace workers (escortists) are pictured at the same level as the kings and caricatures in the middle,
here we draw the imaginary Z axis along the entire drawing
at first glance, the depth will be unseen.
This is vase ...
Most people do not know that the dual and triple motifs are on the back wall
in the drawing frame.
The mirror between the two large canvas and two door frames above
The frames of the following three are matched with the prince and his two servants,
naturally, from the royal and queen to their daughter.
However, at the same time, the views pass from the mirror to the illuminated corridor, where the officer stands.
This illuminated rectangular part is on the same size as the mirror and is on the same line.
Indeed, the brightness of the corridor differs from the light-reflecting image of the small martyrs
and therefore relatively little attention.
These three elements of the "Menin" are the main focal points.
In contrast to the "Last Supper" in which all the figures are depicted around Jesus,
"Menin" is tricky, leaving the audience unstable between a few center of gravity.
The royal family of Velaskes, the court painter of the royal family, and their daughter
it is clear why he does not focus on the whole.
What is the importance of the corridor behind?
There were long disputes around the mirror on the wall.
What side does the autumn reflect?
It is a natural reflection of the royal and queen, standing opposite to some of the critics,
as if the artist had put the audience in their place.
However, a thorough analysis from the other perspective shows that,
where the other side is reflected.
The weakening of the men is not here, but here -
at the door of the illuminated corridor to the right.
What does this mean? That is, the drawings are not in front of the mirror,
they are facing the door. In the mirror, they are directly reflected, but not under a certain angle.
That angle is a point of view of the Men from the invisible aspect -
It reflects Velasquez's flax.
Now let's go back to the two paintings above, as we mentioned earlier.
These are the works of Velasquez's puppet, Peter Paul Rubens.
Both reflect similar stories in Ovidi's Metamorphoses.
In the painting on the right, the mortal Marsias entered the flute to the god Apollon.
On the left, the divine Athina competes with the mortal Araxna.
In other words, two races between humans and gods have been described.
Marsias is defeated, and Araxne is winning, but in the end both are punished by the gods.
Because they do not understand the godliness of coping with craftsmanship.
These stories also apply to Menin, which is a kind,
painting on painting.
During the Velasquez era, painting was not as high as poetry and music.
"Menin" is one of the finest examples of fine art with all the bright effects,
it is a divine inspiration, or the result of accumulated experience throughout life.
All of this goes through the heart of the mirror - from the point of disappearance, multi-centric focus ...
Velasquez tells the audience: "Look, my art is capable of ..."
And to the king and to the rest, he said to them, "Behold,
look at my beautiful look - the most beautiful of yours. "
One of the most remarkable achievements of the Menin era. Impact is infinite.
It is said that IV Philip often came to Velaskes' workshop,
just look at how it works.
In any case, the Men can be able to reflect its meaning after 360 years.
Indeed, while looking at this table at any age, you will gradually be sure that,
you are witnessing one of the most astonishing scenes inherited from medieval works ...
Thank you for viewing :)